Justin Trudeau Prime Minister of Canada
emerges in pictures of blackface the
feds lower rates but President Trump is
enraged anyway and Democrats host teens
to talk about climate change i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
well as so often happens you set up an
entire show only to have it blown up by
Justin Trudeau emerging from the
background dressed as Harry Belafonte
yeah that's a thing that's happening
today we'll get to that in just one
second but first we have to talk about
the importance of life insurance and
life insurance deeply important thing
the fact is that if you're interested in
life insurance you should check out
policy genius but it's not just life
insurance it's also home insurance the
insurance experts of policies unions
don't think that getting home insurance
needs to be complicated that's why
they've reimagined the entire process
you can start by answering a few quick
questions so the team can get to know
you and your property and then policy
genius will do all the work to find you
the best home insurance coverage at the
best possible price with policy genius
you get finalized quotes not estimates
and their team of experts will help you
compare your options side-by-side if you
already have coverage the policy genius
team will shop your policy around if
there's a better rate out there they'll
do all the heavy lifting to get you
switched plus clients who bundled their
home and auto insurance through policy
genius typically save an additional 20%
on their home insurance policy I mean a
lot of states when you buy a home you
have to have home insurance why would
you sit around and wait for somebody to
arrive with more expensive home
insurance for you instead go check out
policy genius.com
today whether you need a home insurance
for a new place or you just want to
reshape your current policy head on over
to policy genius calm today you can get
started on your smartphone right now
that's policy genius the easy way to
compare and buy home insurance once more
policy genius calm and let them know
that we sent you policy genius calm it's
one-stop shop for your insurance needs
ok so Justin Trudeau is the Prime
Minister of Canada he's handsome Bernie
Sanders as I like to say and Justin
Trudeau has made a career out of being
insanely politically correct he has
campaigned on political correctness and
sensitivity and he's a feelings guy
right I mean when he's not snowboarding
and when he's not teaching elementary
school he's Prime Minister and talking
about feelings well it now has emerged
that there are two separate instances in
which Justin Trudeau or either brown
face
or blackface no I do want to make clear
that there are gradations to wrongness
here okay this is not not only my model
I think this is particularly obvious to
anyone who is living right if you are
addressed al jolson style in 1920s
dressed in black face in order to mock
black people that is not quite the same
thing as you dressed up as Michael
Jackson in 1985 when the Thriller video
was huge one is to pay tribute to
Michael Jackson the other is to make fun
of black people obviously there is a
difference
I've asked one Williams at Fox News if
this seems correct to him he says yes
okay so the question is what was Justin
Trudeau actually doing wearing brown
face or black faces now turns out there
are two instances of Justin Trudeau
doing this okay so according to Time
magazine Justin Trudeau's Canada's prime
minister or brown face makeup to a party
at the private school or he was teaching
in the spring of 2001 time has now
obtained a photograph of the incident
the photograph has not been previously
reported the picture was taken at an
Arabian Nights themed gala it shows
Trudeau than the 29 year old son of the
late former Prime Minister Pierre
Trudeau wearing a turban and robes with
his face neck and hands completely
darkened the photograph appears in the
2000-2001 yearbook of West Point Grey
Academy a private day school where
Trudeau was a teacher okay so this is
when he was 29 which is not super young
earlier this month time obtained a copy
of the yearbook the view with the
photograph of Trudeau and brown face
from Vancouver businessman Michael
Adamson who was part of the West Point
Grey Academy community Adamson was not
at the party which was attended by
school faculty administrators and
parents of students
he said he first saw the photograph in
July and felt it should be made public
and that was not the only picture of
Justin Trudeau to emerge Trudeau then
came forward and said that he had worn
black face makeup in high school to
Singh Deo a Jamaican folk song famously
performed by Harry Belafonte and there
is this picture of him from a high
school yearbook dressed up in an afro
and with his face darkened presumably to
sing dale and then tape has now emerged
of him dressed in a very similar outfit
in which he is singing doubt here was
Global News reporting they did confirm
to us last night that we are looking at
Justin Trudeau in this video you can see
that he has black face makeup on it's
covering his face neck his arms and
hands and
you can see between the tears and his
jeans there that he also appears to have
the makeup down his legs as well this as
you mentioned is the third image of him
within about 12 hours that has come out
okay so there are two separate incidents
that we are talking about here there a
bunch of images but two separate
incidents one is this Arabian Nights
party in 2001 when he was teaching at a
private school and the other is
apparently from the early 1990s because
he graduated from high school in the
early 1990s Oh Justin Trudeau comes out
and he makes a statement and his
statement is basically this is racist
stuff I didn't think of it as racist at
the time but it clearly is and I
apologize I take responsibility for my
decision to do that I shouldn't have
done it I should have known better it
was something that I didn't think was
racist at the time but now I recognize
it was something racist to do that I
made a mistake
when
and I wish like that I guess you won all
better them but I didn't and I did it
and I am sorry okay so I think he's
handling it frankly the way he should
handle it right he's taking
responsibility he's saying that what he
did was wrong and he should have known
better but he didn't know better so this
raises a few issues one is the
gradations issue right how bad is the
activity itself and there are gradations
of wrong right just like in all of life
there are gradations of categories of
wrong
so that's issue number one categories
have wrong the second question is if you
participate without intent in racism are
you a racist and this is an interesting
question because there are lots of
people who do stuff that they don't
realize is racist at the time or
discriminatory at the time not even
discriminatory engaging in stereotypes
discrimination implies that you have
actively stopped somebody from advancing
in society racism may just amount to you
involving yourself in stereo typing can
you engage in in racist activity like
dressing up in blackface without knowing
that it was wrongs that make you a
racist and then finally there's the
third question which is the question of
timing and the question of can people
change over time and what kind of
society we want to have so let's go
through these questions one by one try
to break this down in rational fashion
and remember
I don't like Justin Trudeau right as a
politician I think that Justin Trudeau
is wrong on nearly every issue I think
that he stands with the woke scolds in
general and so there is a tremendous
irony so the fact that so many of these
black face or brown face or makeup
photos are now coming out about people
who have spent careers trying to ruin
other careers based on stuff that people
have said thirty years ago right Justin
Trudeau stands firmly in the Volks cold
category and so there's something
deliciously ironic about the fact that
now the crowd is coming for him I don't
think Justin Trudeau would beat there be
out there defending Republican in the
United States if the same thing happened
today right so I'm I'm not defending
just introduce original behavior but I
am going to say I don't think the Justin
Trudeau deserves to lose an election
based on this nor do I think that Justin
Trudeau deserves to be judged as a human
being
they simply on these incidents and I'll
explain why so let's begin with that
first question are there gradation so
the answer is yes there are gradations
to this as I mentioned at the outset al
jolson dressing up in blackface in 1910
1920 is a
very different thing than Justin Trudeau
dressing up as as Aladdin in Arabian
Nights in 2001 hey one is meant
specifically to be derogatory towards
meant to denigrate black people is meant
to make fun of black people the Harry
Belafonte afro is closer to that right
it's closer to that but even there I
really don't think that Justin I have
doubts the Justin Trudeau in the 1990s
was doing other anything other than just
trying to shock people by being
transgressive I highly doubt that Justin
Trudeau meant blackface in the same way
that Al Jolson and company in 1910 1915
meant blackface the sort of Amos and
Andy kind of stuff like I really don't
think that that is what we are talking
about here so there are gradations have
wrong you can still say that the
activity is racist but there are
gradations of racism too okay so that's
point number one point number two is the
question as to what the intent was so
when Justin Trudeau says I participated
in something racist but I didn't know it
was racist that's a really interesting
way to put it and I kind of I kind of
think that that model is worth exploring
a little bit the reason being that
people very often unconsciously do
things that hurt other people I see this
constantly in in the realm of human
behavior people will transgress into
territory that they didn't realize
crossed a line and then when they're
informed that across the line they say
oh well I really didn't mean to say that
I'm sorry I didn't realize that that was
an offensive thing I didn't realize I'd
now engaged in a stereotype that's
really not where I'm meant to go so can
you engage in a racist behavior without
intent two things can be true at once
the behavior can be racist and also you
are not necessarily a racist for
engaging in the behavior if you don't
have the intent to be racist I do think
that an intent is an element of the
crime when it comes to racism and
broadening out the definition of racist
act to make the person who engaged in it
a racist human without any sort of
question of intent being brought to bear
seems weird to me so to take a perfectly
obvious example let's say that you have
a person who is very much on the
political left who dressed up as Michael
Jackson in 1985 at some sort of event is
that the same thing as a men
the KKK dressing up as Michael Jackson
at an event in 1985 I I don't think it
is I really don't think it is I think
that intent is an element of the crime
meaning that the crime is exactly the
same from an objective point of view but
intent does matter to determining the
character of the human being who is
engaged in this and this brings us to
the third point and that is do you think
that Justin Trudeau has matured or
gotten better or or what what does his
career say does his career say that this
is a guy who's a racist does this does
his career say that this is a guy who is
anti-arab because he dressed up in brown
face in 2001 or anti-black because he
dressed up in blackface and danced
around as Harry Belafonte in 1990 right
what what exactly is is Justin Trudeau
as a human being when you're voting
you're basically you're basing your vote
and what you think of the human being in
total I said this about Ralph Northam to
again a politician I despise right for
his policies and I'm personally his
policies are awful and as a person who
went out there and talked basically
openly about the possibility of
infanticide I still said that when that
photo came out of just Ralph Northam and
what really was a truly egregious photo
does that characterize him for the rest
of his life and do we want to live in a
society where he can go back 20 years
and nobody has it we have a time we have
a time machine that only works in one
way I'll explain in just one second
about the time machine that is our
current politics first let's talk about
the coffee that you drink so today is a
day where I need coffee I'm short on
sleep we're doing a lot of work here in
New York City to bring you the very best
in content and that means I need my
coffee I'll tell you what kind of coffee
I prefer that it would be the black
rifle coffee there's nothing quite like
black rifle coffee when it comes to
giving you a kick in the pants with tons
of different roasts to choose from black
rifle shifts ships the best roasts to
order coffee directly to your door and a
portion of all black rifles profits go
to supporting veteran law enforcement
fire and first responder causes when you
drink black rifle coffee you're
supporting a company that serves coffee
and culture to those who truly love
America and if you've been on the fence
about joining black rifle coffee Club
there is no better time than right now
help them reach their goal of hitting a
hundred thousand club members by the end
of this month get access to discounts
and offers not available to other
customers I know the dudes who run black
rifle they are awesome awesome folks
we've had some of them
on the show a lot of veterans a lot of
people who are who are working hard to
work with veterans really terrific folks
visit black rifle coffee comm /ban get
20% off your first purchase that's black
rifle coffee comm / pen for 20% off that
first purchase black rifle coffee comm /
patent okay so Trudeau makes the
statement and to go back to the point I
was making right now we live in an era
in politics in which apology is
considered a sin if you say I did
something 20 years ago but that's not me
we say ah but you did it 20 years ago
didn't you
uh you're a bad person because you did
it 20 years ago and we're gonna bring it
up and we're not gonna let you explain
it we're not gonna let you explain how
you've transformed or why you now
recognize that the thing you did 20
years ago was bad this isn't a parole
hearing this is a public shaming right
this is a Maoist struggle session and we
are going to bring up the thing you said
in the past and it doesn't matter if you
have repented it it doesn't matter if it
embarrasses you and it doesn't embarrass
you just cuz public it embarrasses you
that you ever did that thing and none of
that matters and so you end up with is a
political class in which everybody is
encouraged to double down
so when Trudeau does what I think is the
right thing here and says yes it was me
my responsibility it was a racist thing
I didn't know it was a racist thing and
that doesn't characterize me as a human
being I don't know what more you expect
from him we have a time machine that
only works in one way and that time
machine is excellent at going back and
finding stuff and bringing it back to
the future right going back and getting
the sports book and bringing it back to
the future but there's one problem with
the time machine and that is in the here
and now we do not allow you to justify
your behavior apologize explain we don't
allow that and also when we go back in
time to go get the Biff sports book from
1955 we don't also inform you what's
going to happen in 20 years meaning we
don't tell you how the standards are
going to change
we don't even question you at that time
because we don't have a time machine
that works that way our time machine is
only good at grabbing crap from the past
and bringing it to the now it is not
good at going back and talking to you in
the then so we have no idea what was in
Justin Trudeau's mind when he dressed up
as Harry Belafonte we have no idea what
was in Justin Trudeau's mind when he
dressed up as some dude in Arabian
Nights thing and put on brown makeup and
we really don't have a clue
we don't have any ability to ask him
because again the time machine don't
work that way so instead we have a time
machine that brings back all the bad
stuff but doesn't allow us to explore
your mind at the time so we are supposed
to speculate on your mind at the time
based on that activity and no other data
we're not allowed to take into account
anything you've ever done since and
we're supposed to pretend that you're
the same person now that you were then
and we're supposed to read your activity
in the worst possible light with the
worst possible intent even though the
evidence of intent is lacking that's the
world that people want to create right
now now listen I want Justin Trudeau to
lose that election and I'm not speaking
on behalf of a political point here I'm
speaking on behalf of a culture of
forgiveness in society that makes us
able to live with one another because I
promise you that if we get a time
machine and we go back into everyone's
past there will be something that is
embarrassing and then the only question
for the left really becomes have people
engaged in enough of a struggle session
that we allow them to go in my struggle
session that means that you cave to
certain political priorities like
somehow Ralph Northam has been able to
survive the ire of the left mainly
because he is on the left the Justin
Trudeau will be able to flat sell
flagellate enough that people will let
him go on this thing you know maybe he
pledges to build some affordable housing
maybe he pledges to have meetings with
local Muslim groups to demonstrate how
sorry he is all of this okay but the
reality is we don't know what was in his
head at the time we have no capacity for
forgiveness and we also failed to
recognize that stuff that happened 20
years ago happens in different context
what we have here is a very short term
representation of the longer-term
problem that we now see in teaching
American and world history which is we
go back to 1790 and we look at Thomas
Jefferson like that dude owned slaves
what an evil piece of crap what an evil
- you're a better person than Thomas
Jefferson and maybe you are maybe you
are there were people at the time who
knew that what Thomas Jefferson was
doing was wrong in fact Thomas Jefferson
himself wrote words to the effect that
he sort of knew what he was doing was
wrong all of that may be true but you
weren't there and so you don't really
know do you because you didn't grow up
in a in an era in which slavery was
common you didn't grow up in an area
where slaves work the plantation and
that was considered the normal that
doesn't justify the time and it just
doesn't justify the slavery it does mean
that people grow
and live in the context in which they
grow up and live and a hundred years
from now people are gonna look at pretty
much everything we do and say look at
those awful barbarians and you're gonna
say to yourself well yeah what makes you
better than me well you're not gonna say
things you'll be dead but if you were
alive you would be saying to them what
makes you better than I am you weren't
living in that context you don't know
like you know things now that we didn't
know then now you hear this from your
parents you hear this from your
grandparents you hear this all the time
and it's true it's true and if we have
no capacity for forgiveness of the stuff
that people have done in the past
there's no way to move forward from that
because otherwise we could club each
other over the head about this stuff all
day long but in order for us to have a
productive conversation politically and
as a society generally we we do have to
assume good intentions in the now
doesn't mean I have to assume good
intentions 20 years ago but we do have
to assume good intentions in the now
unless you can provide evidence that
that is untrue and an old photo from 20
or 30 years ago does not prove that your
intentions in the now are bad and if the
idea is that we are going to now change
the assumption and assume that your
intentions in the nail are bad because
something bad that happened and the only
way for you to demonstrate your good
intentions is to do what I want then
this isn't about alleviating problems at
all it's really just about bullying it's
really just a bully tactic I I don't
think that motivations matter too much
when it comes to talking about facts it
is a fact that Justin Trudeau did this
stuff but I think that when it comes to
the way in which we castigate somebody
like Justin Trudeau the motives do
matter and if you're motivated not by
your outrage Justin Trudeau dressing up
in 2001 by the fact that you don't want
them elected Prime Minister of Canada
again then you're doing decency wrong
again this cuts against my political
interest I don't like Justin Trudeau but
that's pretty much the entire point if
you want to live in a society with other
human beings you're going to have to say
yeah grow up and be an adult
honestly grow up and be an adult I'll
explain what I mean by that in just one
second now first speaking of being an
adult one of the things that is gonna
happen as you get older dudes is
likelihood you're gonna lose some hair
well there is a good way to prevent that
hey two out of three dudes will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35 the good
news is with today's advancements in
science
keeps offers proven treatments that can
combat the symptoms of hair loss keeps
has revolutionized the way men are
treated for hair loss used to have to go
to the doctor's office for your hair
loss prescription now thanks to keeps
you can visit a doctor online and get
medication delivered to your home no
more waiting rooms no more pharmacy
checkout lines get doctor attention and
discreet drug delivery all from the
comfort and privacy of your own home
prevention is key I mean there's really
nothing on the market that regrows the
hair that you've lost you really need to
stop the hair loss before it happens
keeps treatments really work they're up
to 90 percent effective and reducing and
stopping further hair loss the sooner
you start using keeps the more hair
you're gonna save so act fast many toos
even experience at least some hair
regrowth with keeps treatments find out
why keeps has more 5-star reviews than
any of its competitors and nearly
100,000 men trust keeps for their hair
loss prevention medication keeps
treatments start at just 10 bucks a
month plus for a limited time and get
that first month for free so if you're
ready to take action and prevent hair
loss go to keeps calm / Ben and keep
that hair you know you're gonna want it
once it's gone you're gonna miss it
keeps calm so I spend get that first
month of treatment for free ke e PS calm
/ Ben go check them out right now okay
so when I say be an adult and I say it's
time to be an adult one of the things
that happens when you are a small child
is you think that your parents are
perfect you think your parents are
perfect you grew up thinking that they
are all wise they're all knowing they're
supremely moral and if you have respect
for your parents you retain that respect
for their moral authority as you get
older but as you get older you also
start to see something weird and that is
that your parents are human beings that
as you become an adult you realize your
parents are other adults and adults the
results and that means that your parents
have made mistakes in their life and now
you have a choice do you wish to spend
the rest of your life castigating your
parents for the mistakes they made with
you on a personal level do you wish to
blame your parents for all of your
problems in the here and now or do you
wish to recognize that your parents had
problems of their own that they maybe
mishandled stuff that you need to
forgive them that because you know your
parents are good people who love you so
do you wish to the image of your parents
as godlike infallible figures who have
never sinned is shattered as you get
older and you have two choices one is to
recognize they're human beings doing the
best that they can and respect them and
love them for that and the other is to
make
contain the image that they should have
been these deeply infallible human
beings who never made a mistake and
thanks to their mistakes all your
problems are their fault only one of
those two mentalities leads a road to a
happier life and that is the first Road
you saying yeah my parents they're
adults they made mistakes they love me
anyway and in fact you appreciate your
parents more for being people because in
spite of all their foibles in spite of
all their flaws they did all this
incredible stuff for you or you can be a
douche and you can spend the rest of
your life going around complaining that
all the problems that your parents
created in your life your parents fault
it's not your fault because you are
infallible you are perfect you have
never made a mistake you can start
seeing something in common with your
parents or you can say well adults
should be infallible I'm infallible all
my problems are my parents fault
okay that's what we have to question as
a society when we look at prominent
figures or any figures really when we
look at our neighbors we have to ask a
question do we expect perfection from
everybody or do we take the generally
more true statement that everyone has
sinned and people are striving to do
their best as a general rule in the face
of their own sinful nature do people
make mistakes and progress from it do we
assume the worst of motives for every
single act or do we assume the worst of
motives for political purposes if we're
doing any of that stuff we are doing
being a human being wrong and we are
making society worse and my fear is that
with all this Justin Trudeau stuff just
as an example and that the whole hubbub
isn't making the society better like we
should we can all be more sensitive
about brown face and black face fine
with me but that's not the purpose here
that the purpose really here is to Club
people into supporting particular points
of view or Club them into behaving in
certain ways that really have nothing to
do with sensitivity or morality and that
the shaming tactics that are now being
applied across a broad range of human
activity are making the world unlivable
and worse and making people less likely
to have fun knowing the ten years from
now you're never gonna be you're not
gonna live it down right that it's it's
the reason why I tell high school
students when I speak on high school and
college campuses and till high school
students college students never post
anything online because the fact is
they're gonna shift the lines and all
the stuff that is innocent today will
now be considered terrible ten years
from now and maybe it is terrible today
but it hasn't occurred to anybody yet
because do you really
if justin trudeau had shown up at that
2001 he's 29 years old he shows up to
that particular they he shows up to that
particular event wearing brown makeup
and one person had gone up to justin
trudeau and said you know justin I'm
really offended by that that really is
offensive to me you think Justin Trudeau
keeps on the makeup I don't I don't I
have no evidence the Justin Trudeau does
that but apparently we have to pretend
that he would that he's a vicious
vicious man or that this is a vicious
vicious behavior and and I don't know
that anybody survives the standard I
really don't I don't know how we lived
together if this is the standard in fact
I think it's standards deliberately
designed to keep us from living with one
another okay meantime in more in other
news that is that is kind of making the
rounds the left is really pushing this
one hard according to the according to
the Washington Post Greg Miller Ellen at
Nakashima and Shane Harris reporting
president Trump's communications with
foreign leader are part of whistleblower
complaints that spurred standoff between
spy chief and Congress former officials
say so that's a really complex headline
so let's try and break it down so they
say the whistleblower complaint that has
triggered a tense showdown between the
US intelligence community and Congress
involves president Trump's
communications with a foreign leader
according to two former US officials
familiar with the matter
Trump's interaction with a foreign
leader included a promise that was
regarded as so troubling it prompted an
official in the US intelligence
community to file a formal whistleblower
complaint with the inspector general for
the intelligence community said the
former officials speaking on the
condition of anonymity because they were
not authorized to discuss the matter
publicly so another leak from the
administration it was not immediately
clear which foreign leader Trump was
speaking with or what he pledged to
deliver but his direct involvement in
the matter has not been previously
disclosed it raised new questions about
the president's handling of sensitive
information and may further strain his
relationships with US spy agencies one
former official said that the
communication was a phone call the White
House declined to comment late Wednesday
night the Office of the Director of
National Intelligence and a lawyer
representing the whistleblower declined
to comment intelligence community
Inspector General Michael Atkinson
determined that the complaint was
credible and troubling enough to be
considered a matter of urgent concern a
legal threshold that requires
notification of congressional oversight
committee so in other words someone in
the Entel community filed a
so-called whistleblower complaints a
whistleblower complaint once filed means
he can't be fired for having blown the
whistle he fired a whistleblower
complaint with the intelligence
community Inspector General and the
Inspector General determined that the
complaint was credible and troubling and
therefore Congress had to be notified
the congressional oversight committees
had to be notified but the acting DNI
Joseph McGuire has refused to share
deals about Trump's alleged transaction
with lawmakers touching off a legal and
political dispute that has spilled into
public view and prompted speculation
that the spy chief is improperly
protecting the president so the head of
the DNI he said no I'm not turning that
over so basically he disagrees with the
Inspector General of the intelligence
community and this once again raises the
big problem of unitary executive theory
versus the idea that there are
independent agencies within the
executive branch so under Justice
Scalia's unitary executive theory and
the Constitution of the United States
once you delegate power from the
legislature to the executive branch
everybody in the executive branch works
for the president he's the head of the
executive branch so if something happens
that is bad within the executive branch
then the notion that those people can
simply determine in the absence of
running it up the chain of command what
to do and then answer only to Congress
creates serious balance of power issues
because what you really could end up
with is the Congressional branch running
in the light of running the executive
branch you're gonna you can end up with
the legislature running the executive
with a bunch of unelected officials who
were appointed by Congress and then left
there forever right and that is a
serious problem you end up with an
unanswerable branch of Congress in the
bureaucracy but that runs up against
situations like this like what if the
whistleblower complaint is actually a
serious problem what if the
whistleblower is actually making a
complaint that is that is in that is
criminal in nature well so this is where
you end up with these sort of
constitutional crisis the crisis
questions the dispute is expected to
escalate Thursday when Atkinson is
scheduled to appear before the House
Intelligence Committee in a classified
session
close to the public hearing is the
latest move by committee chairman Adam
Schiff to compel US intelligence
officials to disclose the full details
of the whistleblower complaint to
Congress McGuire has agreed
to five before the panel next week he
declined to comment for the article
according to chef who has fibs about
this kind of stuff in the past with
regard to Russia the Inspector General
determined the complaint is both
credible and urgent the complaint was
filed with Adkinson office on August
12th a date on which Trump was at his
Golf Resort in New Jersey White House
records indicate the trumpet had
conversations or interactions with at
least five foreign leaders in the
preceding five weeks among them was a
call with Russian President Vladimir
Putin the White House initiated on July
31st Trump also receives at least two
letters from Kim Jong Un's during the
summer it also could have been the Prime
Minister of Pakistan the prime minister
of the Netherlands or the Emperor of
Qatar so because Putin's name is on the
list this has led people to speculate
the Trump made some sort of promise to
Putin that was SuperDuper law-breaking
and that somebody in the intelligence
community then notified the inspector
general blew the whistle and the whistle
and in the inspector general was like
okay you got to go tell Congress and
then the head of the director the head
of the the national intelligence
community said no you don't statements
and letters exchanged between the
Offices of the DNI and the House
Intelligence Committee in recent days
have pointed at the White House without
directly directly implicating the
president Schiff has said he was told
the complaint concerned conduct by
someone outside of the intelligence
community the dispute has put McGuire
thrust into the DNA job in an acting
capacity with the resignation of Daniel
Coates last month at the center of a
politically perilous conflict with
constitutional implications Schiff is
demanding full disclosure of the
whistleblower complaint McGuire is
defending his refusal by saying that the
subject of the complaint is beyond his
jurisdiction in other words a member of
the Intel community filing a complaint
about the president that doesn't fall
under the intelligence auspices right
that's presidential activity and if the
Congress wants to subpoena Trump and
have him testify or if the Congress
wants to issue we pass laws to that
effect they can do it defenders of
Maguire dispute he's subverting legal
requirements to protect Trump saying
he's trapped in a legitimate legal
predicament and he has made his
displeasure clear to officials at the
Justice Department and the White House
by law Maguire is required to transmit
complaints to Congress within seven days
in this case you refrain from doing so
because you
to the Justice Department for some sort
of guidance and they said you're not
allowed to turn this stuff over
legal experts according to the
Washington Post say there are scenarios
in which the president's communications
with a foreign leader could rise to the
level of an urgent concern for the
intelligence community but they also
noted that the president has brought
authority to decide unilaterally lens
declassify or classify information so in
other words if he was somebody in the
Intel community who is basically
suggesting oh you know what we don't
like the Trump gave this info to Putin
all Trump has to do is say boom do you
classify it we're done here so we are
likely to find out I think in the very
near future what exactly the complaints
against Trump is it'll be a big blow up
we'll wait to see until then exactly
whether this is indeed a matter of deep
and abiding concern okay in just a
second we're going to get to the Fed
rate making a move and president Trump
being pretty unhappy about it but first
you're gonna have to go over to Daly
wire.com and subscribe when you do you
get the rest of the ben shapiro show you
got it all i'm talking about two
additional hours per day i'm talking
about me talking at you and with you for
two additional hours a day I'm talking
about you get our Sunday special on
Saturday this week you're definitely
want gonna want to tune in to the Sunday
special and get the material we have
behind the paywall our final question
because Kennedy from Fox Business
Network stopped by and it was great
here's a little bit of what that sounded
like anytime something happens and it
feels like it's beyond our control the
knee-jerk is we need more government as
if government is going to solve things
government naturally doesn't do that
it's the opposite it's just layers and
layers of suffocating bureaucracy that
that collapses under the weight of its
own good intentions
so Kenny stopped by a lot of libertarian
talk so if you're into libertarianism
this is a big thing so go check it out
bench Bureau Sunday special with Kennedy
this weekend and when you subscribe to
get a little bit early also with the
annual subscription you know the pitch
you get this right look at this cup it's
a nice cup go get it anything Bugsy here
yet the annual subscription comes along
with all the goodies and it's cheaper
than the monthly we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
okay so the Federal Reserve has decided
that it is time to lower the benchmark
interest rate according to The Wall
Street Journal the Federal Reserve cut
its benchmark interest rate by a quarter
percentage point for the second time in
as many months to cushion the economy
against a global slowdown amplified by
the us-china trade war now President
Trump had of course been calling on the
Federal Reserve to lower interest rates
he wants them to keep lowering and keep
lowering and keep lowering the idea
being that if they do that Spurs
borrowing and lending and that that will
jog the economy Fed Chairman Jerome
Powell left the door open to additional
cuts and repeatedly cited the costs of
rising trade policy uncertainty but
central bank officials are split over
Wednesday's decision and the outlook for
further reductions see there's this
weird catch-22 politically speaking the
president Trump is in with regard to the
economy on the one hand if the economy
is really going gangbusters if the
economy is really super strong there's
no real reason for a rate cut if the
economy is strong you don't need to cut
rates to quote unquote spur growth and
spur spending and boost lending in all
of this if however the rates are
continuously lowered that indicates that
Trump thinks that the economy is
starting to turn south which cuts
against his reelect efforts so which one
do you want do you want the rate cut and
the implication that the economy is
slowing or would you prefer no rate cut
and maybe the economy slows so those are
that's the real question for president
Trump Jerome Powell said there will come
a time I suspect when we think we've
done enough but there may also come a
time when the economy worsens and we
would then have to cut more aggressively
we don't know which is sort of what he
is supposed to be saying at this point
like why are we forecasting further rate
cuts if you really believe that we need
a big rate cut right now he'd just make
one he wouldn't wait several months in
order to make another rate cut you could
just cut it right now US stocks wobbled
then pared losses after the feds
decision
Treasury yields which move inversely to
prices ticked higher though held their
recent range meaning that people that
okay maybe the economy is stabilizing a
little bit markets have been looking to
the Fed for more concrete promises of
rate cuts but Powell has been reluctant
to make any the trade related risks are
out of the feds control and difficult to
predict officials are divided over how
to respond in other words the tariff war
is having a toll on the American economy
if from were to cut some sort of deal
with the Chinese that probably helped
the economy and then you don't need to
cut rates but Jerome Pella has no idea
what's gonna happen because nobody has
any idea what's going to happen
seven of the ten Fed officials voted in
favor of lowering the benchmark federal
funds rate to arrange between 1.75
percent in two percent with two Reserve
Bank presidents preferring to hold rates
steady and one favoring a larger half
point cut the Fed also on Wednesday
injected money into the banking system
for the second day in a row to ease a
crunch and overnight funding market said
it would do so again on Thursday the
operations are our aims at keeping the
Fed Funds rate in the central bank's
target range that is not a crisis move
so people are trying to see that as okay
the feds had to intervene in the banking
system because people are withdrawing
too much money from the banking system
okay that's not what happened people are
withdrawing money and expectation of
paying their quarterly taxes Powell said
that the funding issues and the feds
operations have no implications for the
economy or the stance of monetary policy
and he continued a signal uncertainty
about the trade war president Trump is
pissed off anyway soon after the Fed
announced its rate cut which he has been
calling for Trump lashed out he said Jay
Powell and the Federal Reserve fail
again
he said no guts no sense no vision a
terrible communicator how declined to
talk about he said I continue to believe
the independence of the Federal Reserve
from direct political control has served
the public well over time and he said
that the Fed will continue to conduct
monetary policy without regard to
political considerations and bottom line
is that we just don't know which
direction the economy is going president
Trump wants the rates cut because he
figures again what's the worst that can
happen all right let's hit the economy
is going strong if we cut the rates
maybe it'll grow even stronger the Fed
did estimate that there would be growth
this quarter or its GDP forecast for
slightly up to two point one percent but
that or two point two percent but that
is not the kind of rate that President
Trump was aiming for when he came into
office he was suggesting three or even
maybe four percent growth this obviously
is not that the central bank now expects
GDP to grow at a 2.2 percent pace for
2019 versus the 2.1 percent forecast in
june the unemployment rate is expected
to rise a little bit this year according
to CNBC slightly above the three point
six percent projection in June the GDP
outlook for 2020 is still two percent
which again is not great it's not not
horrible not great not really much of
anything not
to sink Trump's presidential hopes for
2020 but not enough to automatically
boost him into the White House again
meanwhile speaking of those presidential
hopes the 2020 Democratic candidates are
at it again Elizabeth Warren and there's
some talk about how she's broadening her
coalition it is true Bernie Sanders has
a very narrow coalition his coalition is
basically white young people and Joe
Biden's coalition is white old people
and black people dad that is his
coalition Elizabeth Warren has very
solid support among white upper-class
liberals and then she has mid-range to
low support among every other group but
there is room for her to move up the
problem for Elizabeth Warren is that in
order to steal more support from Bernie
and finally overtake Biden in the polls
she keeps having to move left and she
keeps pandering and she keeps getting
Wars and the the sort of read on
Elizabeth Warren broadly speaking is
that she's sincere Hillary Clinton I
don't think that's right I think she's
more talented than Hillary but I don't
think she's sincere in any way shape or
form I don't think she believes half the
things that she is saying I think when
she does the the full Ron woke routine
when she is suggesting she wants
Medicare for all but she's not gonna
raise middle-class taxes and when she
goes out and she starts playing the
Hillary Clinton men have no part in
American history card I don't think she
believes any of this stuff it really is
a is a radical departure from what she
used to be when she was at Harvard Law
School for example so Elizabeth Warren
spoke in New York City a couple of days
ago and she dropped this astonishing
line we are not here because of men I am
especially glad to be here in Washington
Square Park I wanted to give this speech
right here and not because of the arch
behind me or the president that this
square is named for nope we're not here
today because of famous arches or famous
men in fact we're not here because of
man that
we're here because of some hardworking
women oh is that the whole story of New
York City is it really I missed the part
where men were completely irrelevant to
the story of New York City weird weird
if this is the pitch and I this stuff is
going to live on into the general
election and her insulting George
Washington and insulting men Hey she's
got a gender gap she understand she has
a gender gap and she's trying to
exacerbate the gender gap by appealing
to women but I don't think that she's
winning over additional women and that's
particularly true in the areas of the
country that she needs to win does
Elizabeth Warren I mean the fact is that
Joe Biden in a general election is still
the most threatening candidate to
president Trump for two reasons one he
feels non-threatening and two he's got
the legacy of Barack Obama to run on and
people still have warm feelings for
Barack Obama personally and they've
extended those to Joe Biden but what
you're starting to see from the
Democratic Party is a turn away from
even Barack Obama era semi rationality
it's amazing Farhad Manjoo who is one of
the ID's of the the Democratic
establishment he rides rights over for
the New York Times one of the brilliant
myriad brilliant intellects on their
editorial page has a piece today called
Barack Obama's biggest mistake and that
what is that big mistake that Barack
Obama still believed heavily in free
markets even though Barack Obama was a
massive interventionist in the free
markets he says after the financial
crash Democrats had a once-in-a-lifetime
political opportunity presented by a
careening global crisis across the
country people were losing jobs and
homes and numbers not seen since World
War two if he'd been in the mood to
press the case Obama might have found
widespread public appetite for the sort
of aggressive interventionist
restructuring of the American economy
that FDR conjured with the New Deal one
of the inspiring new president's
advisors even hinted that that was the
plan
and then quotes rahm emanuel saying you
never want a serious crisis to go to
waste now this seems to ignore the fact
that Barack Obama tried to ram through
Obamacare and really failed to do so in
the fashion that he originally suggested
and had to cut a bunch of deals and then
got the Affordable Care Act and that was
so unpopular that Democrats across the
country lost their seats but according
to Farhad Manjoo the lesson of Obama is
that the left didn't pull far left
enough
Farhad Manjoo said rather than try for a
Roosevelt II and home run he bunted
instead of pushing for an aggressive
stimulus to rapidly expand employment
and long term structural reforms and how
the economy worked Obama and his team
responded to the recession with a set of
smaller emergency measures designed to
fix the immediate collapse of financial
markets did they he spent four trillion
dollars his first year in office he
spent seven hundred billion dollars on
tarp
he said the recession didn't turn into a
depression or on his stimulus package
rather he said the recession didn't turn
into a depression markets were
stabilized the united states began a
period of long slow growth but they
could have done so much more
he should have spent 1.2 trillion
dollars on government stimulus instead
he only pushed for 800 billion yeah that
was the big deal and of course he failed
to push for a radical restructuring of
the American economy but now is the time
now is the time of course he's pushing
for Elizabeth Warren he says think of
Obama is a cautionary tale a story that
ought to rank at the top of mind for a
Democratic electorate that is now
choosing between Obama's vice president
and progressives like Bernie Sanders or
Elizabeth Warren who had pushed Obama
during the recovery to adopt policies
with more egalitarian economic effects
Elizabeth Warren really only pushed for
going after big banks that was pretty
much for policy from this distance as
Farhad Manjoo the history favors
Warren's approach so the problem isn't
that Barack Obama made business
extraordinarily uneasy with his heavy
hand of regulation with his increases in
taxes no the real problem is that he
didn't fully embrace the Elizabeth
Warren Bernie Sanders plan and this is
the direction the Democratic Party is
moving but in order to do that they have
to declare a complete break with the
Obama years and that means declaring a
complete break with Joe Biden and the
new attack on Joe Biden so they've tried
a few attack number one was that Joe
Biden is too old that really has not
gone very much of any more attack number
two is that Joe Biden is a racist that
again is not really gonna go much of
anywhere and then there is attack number
three and that is that Joe Biden is too
nice and this one may actually work this
may actually work as Democrats are
ticked off Democrats hate President
Trump they have been driven around the
bend by Trump derangement syndrome a lot
of Democrats believes in the aftermath
of Barack Obama the Democrats would
never lose an election again that was
the demographic promise all the groups
in America that were increasing in terms
of their demographics or voting Democrat
and therefore there is no chance of
Republican would ever win again the
Obama 2012 coalition assured in a new
era in American politics in which could
lose heavy shares of the white vote and
still win general election and then
Donald Trump came along he beat Hillary
Clinton and Democrats had to cope with
what had happened and so they could
choose one or two narratives one is
Donald Trump represents a racist
backlash but it's an aberration and
it'll go away and the other one is maybe
we ought to start thinking about some of
those white voters we alienated with all
of our intersectional identity politics
nonsense and instead they chose the
instead they chose the Donald Trump as
an aberration he's probably gonna go
away and we need to treat Republicans
like scum and treat everybody who
disagrees with us like some sort of
horrible person and this is how you
arrived at the third attack on Joe Biden
so we've had again he's a racist nope
he's old yeah and finally that he is too
nice to Republicans in the New York
Times today there's peace by Glen thrush
titled Joe Biden believes in the
goodwill of Republicans is that naive
now first of all Joe Biden basically
called the Tea Party terrorists and
suggested that if you don't want your
taxes increased that you are not
patriotic in the United States so I'm
not gonna completely buy this Joe Biden
is a wonderful friend to Republicans
line at least not publicly now privately
he is good friends with a lot of
Republicans and I know a lot of
rock-ribbed Republicans who feel the
chill Biden is a nice guy they can talk
with him negotiate with him but
according to the New York Times that's
very bad and it needs to be stopped so
according to the New York Times again
this is a news piece not an opinion
piece Mitch McConnell the Senate
Republican leader and self-described
grimly reaper of liberal legislative
dreams settled into a routine of sorts
during Barack Obama's second term
whenever he felt he was cornered by
Democrats McConnell would rise from his
chair in the Capitol walked to his
schedulers desk smile a tight smile and
asked can we get Joe Biden on the phone
that was precisely what happened in late
2012 when Republicans were in the
minority and McConnell hit an impasse
with Harry Reid over the elimination of
Bush era tax cuts for the wealthy again
this is a news piece
unbelievable as in New Year's Eve
deadline approached Biden and mr.
McConnell hammered out an agreement in a
dozen phone calls aides to both men said
with Obama signing off on every move the
two sides struck a deal that delivered
some but far from all of what Reid
wanted this year as he runs for
president biden cites that seal and
others he cut with mcconnell has proof
of his skill in achieving bipartisan
legislation in an otherwise hyper
partisan environment biden said this
month I'll work with Mitch McConnell
where we can agree he said there were
some issues like gun control where there
is no room for compromise that he would
agree with mr. McConnell on anything is
a controversial statement for any
Democrat to make these days but in a
sprawling field of 20 candidates Biden
stands out for his enduring belief in
the good will of congressional
Republicans he insists that the GOP has
been bullied by President Trump but that
civility and compromise will return to
Washington once Trump is gone now the
reality is that Biden doesn't even
believe that Biden believes that if he
could that he could probably get a deal
done now right with Trump in office he
believes that deals are there to be done
he's just saying that because he's
running against Trump it's a view that
has been branded naive and wistful by
some Democratic rivals as well as by the
ascendant left wing of his party that
criticism is particularly pointed with
regard to McConnell whose decision to
block Obama's nomination of Merrick
garland to the Supreme Court elevated
him from mere obstructionist to
arch-villain in the eyes of many
Democrats now this attack may stick and
the reason it may stick is because Joe
Biden is violating a crucial rule that
rule is you have to demonize Republicans
as evil horrible human beings and Biden
does that sometimes but other times he
does not and Elizabeth Warren has fallen
into the the habit of doing it on a
routine basis and Bernie Sanders of
course does it all the time well this is
the attack that could be a problem for
Joe Biden but the fact is that if you
knock Biden out of the box with this
attack then you provide a parallel
problem and that's the problem for
Elizabeth Warren there's a piece by paul
ster roban journalist based in orleans
massachusetts suggesting that Elizabeth
Warren's critical vulnerability is that
white working-class voters in
Pennsylvania Michigan and Wisconsin
aren't interested in her wild-eyed
progressivism so in other words all the
stuff that makes Biden unpalatable in a
primary again is the stuff that makes
him palatable in general and vice versa
with Elizabeth Warren alrighty time for
a quick thing that I like and then a
quick thing that I hate so things that I
liked
so there's a piece of good news today
America's abortion rate has now dropped
to its lowest its lowest ever fewer
pregnancies maybe more responsible for
the decline than state laws restricting
abortion says the New York Times is of
course what they're going to suggest
abortion in the United States has
decreased to record low levels good
fewer children and incipient children
and the womb being killed good a decline
that may be driven more by increased
access to contraception and fewer women
becoming pregnant than by the
proliferation of laws restricting
abortion in some states according to new
research abortion rates decrease in
almost every state there's no clear
pattern linking these declines to new
restrictions right but there is a clear
pattern linking these declines to the
restrictions in the sense that the
overwhelming wave in American public
opinion is that more and more people are
recognizing that a baby in the womb is
in fact a baby in the womb and that's
driving both the laws and the trend on
an individual level for people to have
fewer abortions just as in the opposite
way in the 1970s the weird assumption
that children were not children that
abortion was immoral good led to both a
rollback in laws and to an increase in
abortion simultaneously but that is a
very good piece of news and we should
note it
hey in other things that I like today
this is just a wonderful wonderful story
Warren dukkha who has been a guest on
our radio program she's she's a former
Teen Vogue columnist most famous for
going at it with Tucker Carlson on his
television show according to a BuzzFeed
at news profile her students in feminism
and journalism in New York University
filed a formal complaint why because it
turns out she's terrible at her job
according to BuzzFeed news nearly four
weeks after the course ended her student
sent a collective formal complaint to
the heads of the NYU journalism school
about Dukas conduct five out of the ten
students had similar allegations against
dukkha and class structure
they said the dukkha didn't follow her
own syllabus that she spoke often and
inappropriately about her personal life
that she would belittle and yell at
students and most pressingly that she
targeted one student in particular
apparently she even used certain slurs
to to deal with a student is according
to the BuzzFeed report they claimed that
she would disappear for thirty to
forty-five minutes per class to meditate
which is incredible she would belittle
one student
in particular apparently the the
students describe the course as quote a
waste of six weeks for all of us and
it's an one student told BuzzFeed it's
frustrating to see as a student as a
young woman see how somebody can so
clearly take advantage of the system and
capitalize on her suppose it woke Ness
well I'm not practicing what she's
writing about Lauren Zuko respondents
abuzz feed it's okay if I'm not a great
teacher because I'm great and a lot of
other things which is just spectacular
that is absolutely spectacular you're
you weren't hired for the other things
lady you were hired for the teaching
part of it and by the way a fond hello
to Laurens hookahs journalism class
she came on my radio program and
apparently like played it the interview
in the class while she was doing it it
didn't go fantastically for her so
Lauren Zuka professor to the Stars okay
you know what we're gonna skip things
that I hate today because we've run out
of time but we'll be back here tomorrow
with much much more so we'll see you
then
or see you late here later today for two
additional hours I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo white house key
edited by Adam Tsai events audio is
mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Jessica ov era
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
if you want to delve the depths of
leftist madness head on over to the
Michael Noel's show where we examine
what's really going on beneath the
surface of our politics and bask in the
simple joys of being right
[Music]
you